all right now to a brutal storm system
battering the South look at these
pictures from Arkansas showing the
aftermath of a reported tornado it's the
same system that brought record rainfall
to the West Coast and it's not done yet
Janet shamlian has more from Little Rock
light poles snapped in half bleachers
flung from the stands and a mangled
scoreboard this is the jesseville high
school football field after a strong
storms and a possible tornado slammed
Western Arkansas just out of the blue
high winds things begin the awnings
begin to blow away we didn't have any
prior warning inside the school debris
littered classrooms is more than 900
students took cover very thankful that
we didn't have any injuries buildings
can be repaired trees will grow back
things like that
the storm also slamming Union Parish
Louisiana where damaged homes and ripped
trees from their Roots you can see the
weather is starting again it's the same
Community still reeling from a series of
tornadoes just last month
the system is part of the line of storms
delivering record rain to Northern
California Crews there are still in
rescue mode this morning after the
powerful system flooded streets
Lupe Rodriguez became trapped in her
flooded car near Sacramento after going
to check on her parents my tires were
just not that bad all of a sudden
there's a loop that got me down and that
was it that was done
as residents continue the cleanup
they're now bracing for the next one
officials spent Monday ensuring levees
aren't reached again with more rain
expected by Saturday and the system now
heads East through the Rockies
delivering heavy snow and prompting
Avalanche warnings
here in Little Rock they're still
dealing with rain but this system is on
the move the storm now moving into
places like Georgia and Alabama with the
threat of flooding and tornadoes in
Minnesota potential ice storms today and
airlines are warning of potential
cancellations across the entire region
Adriana
Janet thank you